go ahead
okay for people joining this live stream
this is a
design review about sound and vision
sound and
images and video for wolverine language
version 12.3
all right so let's see
why am i seeing this example data what
what is this an example of
this is um the evolution of the rule 30
we had a rule 30 wave in our example
data in the layout now if you call
um not that if you say video of that
string
you're gonna get that video
i bet that this has smart quotes in it
but otherwise let's see what you get
by the way i assume that the video
player is now genuinely in line
no it's not next version there there has
been great progress from the front end
for having library link support and
video is going to be the first user of
it
but not this version next why is this
top cut off
um if if you it's not cut off i can pad
it if you think that's better but um
it's there it's just a quick time
that's cool but what am i seeing here
i know it's rule 30 but i mean i'm
asking what is the technology that i'm
seeing here
i used video generator but really we
wanted a
quick short video in in the layout that
we can use for
documentation examples and whatnot
so that that's just that addition we
need more complicated examples that
we're going to add to
data repository now that there is
zip file support for assets that that
are distributed with that data
repository that's a new feature
and we're going to use it to to add
examples of
people and cars and whatever that we can
demo our capabilities
it's a weird example because it has it
has very sharp black and white pieces
i mean i you know i'm i'm a big fan of
the picture but i'm just i'm just saying
it could be maybe a little bit of a
weird case what's that could be useful
to demonstrate structural operations and
videos rather than
focusing on the content fair enough
fair enough because it has a definite um
you can tell which part of the video
you're in by how far down it's grown
yeah that helps no i agree
i mean you could also do one that
is a you know more like a you know a
snowflake growth cellular automaton
going from the center
sure might also be um
i can give you one of those if you want
one um i'm sure we've made
um this is just the sort of equivalent
of lena
right um
some of the ones that grow like this are
kind of fun
you know you can kind of easily see
what's happening and uh
um let's see
well we can we can generate one of these
this is easy i mean just go to the
cellular automaton
documentation um
perhaps we can get this done offline but
this should be
super easy to do uh
yep i will get something yeah i agree
this is nice
just for fun something well this one may
flash a lot because it's got um
maybe not um but just
just to get some sense of how let me see
the workflow actually
of how would i turn this into a video
you wanna um video generator has one
example
that shows that and that's um that's
tentative because
we have so you have to open the uh
source notebook
but that's sensitive because we're
adding an argument that says
the function that generates frame
that generates the frames what are the
variable what what are the values that
are passed to
the function so instead of it always
being the time that it was the case
before now we are adding this start and
end
clear the argument so up in this
usage box there is a third argument
start and end
so for the duration zero to time we can
say
start passing values start
to end sampled in that interval to the
function so i can say you know
specifically useful if you want to do
intervals of one
like pass all the integers to the
function for instance
so that comma and then
the 30 should be hash
i'll make that whole thing a function
second argument is the duration let's
say we want it for
two seconds so 15 frames per second
and then uh one comma 30.
okay actually i have to do one thing
here which is to i should change the
size here and see
and probably you have to do round of
hash because
has to be an imager but why
i mean i can run this while we're
talking but but why um this isn't
quite gonna do the right thing because
this needs to turn into a center array
okay we're spinning why are we spinning
and why don't we use a progress
indicator
so the focus indicator should be enabled
so there is clearly some
something else that is going on there is
this
prototype yes i'm not sure if
how the situation is would you mind
running
like the first uh example in the dark
notebook just to make sure that
stuff is not broken in prototype which
no which documentary the video generator
uh well i would if i could interrupt
anything but i can't oh really oh wow
that's
that's uh that's concerning
um
yeah it looks like there is some issue
with the prototype
okay okay i'll have to kill it and
restart
um
meanwhile we have um questions from
ethan
what about 3d video my gosh our users
are so
they expect everything but do we have
anything like that
not yet i've looked at it a couple of
times but there is so much
for 2d videos is
what kind of format is that backed by
because i assume it needs to be in some
kind of file format
i actually don't remember i don't know
all right let's start up the prototype
build again
actually ethan is saying he says 3d
videos all the time on oculus so there
must be a format for that what in earth
is it
because that definitely wasn't
standardized i mean you know the the
the more common thing is you just use
some uh
um
i think i think that the 3d format is
just two
left and right for oculus right it's not
i say it's not a genuine 3d geometry
hastings comedy and kill it in the
tunnel without killing the front that is
a that's an interesting
good point life-changing
okay there was a question here about is
there's still no way to crop a video
spatially
we could um the video frame map
can uh map a video crop and image crop
over frames
yes well that presumably would work i
mean if i just say video of this thing
here
um
and then i say video frame map
of image crop what are the arguments of
measurements
slot comma hundred hundred
[Music]
right it's very fuzzy but
it did that it's fuzzy because
you enlarged it it's hundred by hundred
images yeah i understand
but as well the um encoding is gonna
cause some fuzziness anyways for this
kind of a as you said black and white
video
right image assembling multiple videos
video map and the family video frame map
video
map time series all of those are being
updated to take
multiple video sources so one can do
image compose image assemble again very
similar to what you're calling there
just that slot is going to take a list
of images
i see but what about the how do you
conform i mean if they don't time
conform your out of luck
we have discussed how we conform in
size and there is a new option we're
proposing frame fitting i'm open to name
proposal for that
for now for temporal fitting we are
using our own defaults not providing any
options or arguments which is typically
padding with fixed frame
in time the video tracks and silent for
audio tracks
we may think about providing options for
changing the defaults in the future
one note i want to add we do our best to
guarantee
that things that you are assembling or
joining
or whatever are the temporal
alignment is respected so for example if
you have
two videos of different frame rate the
second one will be
or the one with the lower framework rate
will be a sample
to the frame rate
of the one with the higher frame rate so
the frames
are extracted at the same times but how
do you align the zero of time
it's just assumed to be when each video
starts whereas
if if they are if the tracks are not
aligned
in terms of start offsets then it is
just padded
okay okay i'm sorry but but how do you
do we in the metadata for a video we
have a start time
that is different from its absolute
start time i mean
it's different from its in video
how do we there is no notion of absolute
time that the video was captured at
but there is an offset that you can say
this video starts
a few seconds late and that's when we do
the padding that carlo mentioned
how do you specify the offset um it's a
metadata as you said it's stored as a
start time and that's another addition
in this version our import is being
updated
to provide us with that information from
metadata
so you'll have to extract a specif
the specific
bit of the information which is not
displayed by default because it's an
expensive operation to compute
and i think it might be exact time
exact track durations if i am not
mistaken
um no no with information video comma
property
um and i might be mistaken about the
correct name but i can
exact track durations durations
i think i i can go fetch up the correct
name
but that's gonna give us the durations
we have exact time boundaries and track
start times being added to import
as elements yeah sorry i couldn't
remember the correct name
what was the name
exact time boundaries is one
and you have to pass it to import i
don't think it's accessible
in information we should have everything
in information that is an
input okay well anyway it's coming so
okay so this thing here is the generic
information about a video
all metadata so the the video itself is
not
part of this yes
bitrate bits per second okay
um okay well it looks cool
all right video generator that's the
thing you were just mentioning but i
wasn't really internalizing how it
worked
correct let me go back to that video
generator
okay so the basic idea of video
generator is you have a function
this is like the analog of table but for
a video
yes statement it's also the analog of
kind of
play or something
i think it's kind of closer to play and
array than table but yeah that kind of
thing
well except that the model here takes as
a pure function
it doesn't need to be a pure function it
can be a function
well but can it be a function can it be
some expression that depends on t
uh it needs to be an expression
for example you can define it with down
values it doesn't need to be
explicit function it could be f of
something so the answer is
as long as you defined just as array
takes a function
yes just as a you know table tennis
expression
array takes a function yeah and i think
t there is wrong we should rename that
variable to duration because it's really
i think we should
have two because everything is very
confusing now that i see it here
yeah it looks super comple it kind of
looks like a variable t
i agree right
okay so but maybe you should say video
generation of fun
comma duration or something for the
function yeah
yeah i think it should be too the only
thing is that
model can be other things like a a
single image or a list of images
that we iterate through but i agree the
function
case is really important that probably
the usage box
should immediately include it fine
okay so now what's new and different
here
so this has always been that duration
but then
and when did it sample i mean i don't
understand what some
so the function used to get values from
0 to t sampled at the specified
frame rate we have some defaults for
frame rate you can change it
now if in the case of that cellular
automaton evolution you really want to
pass
values from 1 to n to the function
and not 0 to 1 but still generate it for
whatever duration
you can now specify 1 comma 30 in that
third argument
and that duration is is sampled with
respect to the duration and frame rate
but so to me it would be nice if you
could say start end and then a step
there because you know if we assume
that the model function is a pure
function so to speak
then you know you wouldn't have to right
now in that cellular automaton thing i
suspect we were
goofily sampling you know hundreds and
hundreds of times
and just rounding them all to the same
value am i making sense
you do i propose that as well but then
the arguments are conflicting the
duration
frame rate and then the start and step
are not always going to give us it it
ended up being conflicting
why with start and with start and
step you generate so many frames
and with t frame rate combination as
well
you you specify how many frames to be
generated total
and if those two numbers don't matter
what do we do
we think about it for a second okay so
the duration
you're saying given the duration and the
frame rate option value
right yep which says there's a frame
rate option value
right which can be set to like 30 frames
a second or whatever yes
and given that that tells you the
integer number of frames that you're
going to generate
right okay so now
that final argument is simply mapping
uh kind of what is the data range what
what is the
what are the what are the values that
you want to within that duration
you are initially saying map that
duration
by in equally spaced bins between start
and end
correct okay so that implies
that given a frame rate there's a delta
t there
okay so i don't understand why there's a
problem because basically
if i give you a big crunchy delta t
that is many frame rate delta t's
just be happy you have to do fewer
evaluations
i'm not saying you change the frame rate
i'm saying that
there are situations where you're doing
discrete things
where you can
sample it once and lay it down a hundred
times
in the actual video okay
carlo you disagree with that i i see
what you're saying so so you're saying
so you're asking essentially about
caching an operation that would happen
at non-rounded times
that's correct i'm saying let's say that
the video you want to make
like in this you know in the example of
the cellular automaton thing
okay you know
it in the end a video
as in a video encoder is going to be
picking up the video
you know every 30th or second or
whatever it is right
correct and it has no choice about that
but what i'm saying is
the actual video might only change every
second
so what i'm saying so don't i think one
way to think about it steven is that if
you specify start and step
you specify a frame rate because you
specify duration
then you specify frame rate again and
now you're going to merge the two
i know but the whole point is that the
frame rate that you're specifying
is the frame rate for the video encoder
it's not
the you know it's the frame rate at
which you're going to be sampling it for
the sake of
painting it on your screen it's not the
rate that you're sampling it
with respect to you know the underlying
generation of the thing
so you're proposing essentially having
two separate frame rates one for
that's correct and one for saving yeah
because i think think about the cellular
automaton case
you do not want a frame rate in which
every frame of the cellular automaton
is necessarily a single frame of the of
the final video
that's right right it will be way too
fast
i mean that's not necessarily true right
if you set a
low enough frame rate then it doesn't
really matter you
you can do exactly how does that work in
a video encoder does that work in a
video encoder
yeah you can yeah really yeah if you set
a low frame rate
you just generate at that frequency i
i understand that but i i would suspect
that your average player
if i said oh i'm not playing at 30th of
a sec you know
30 frames a second i'm playing it at at
you know
0.2 frames per second does it really
work
that we've done yes
i've tested like up to like one frame
per second i haven't gone
fractional i i haven't checked that
right well okay i i would
not trust you know standard video
players to be able to deal with things
that aren't
that's reasonable the um
so just to give you one more bit of
context that this kind of syntax
is kind of inspired by the array one
where the third argument does
pretty much the same thing
as the okay
the third argument of array
usually has a start it doesn't have an
end could
have an end i think we added that later
than the initial introduction but then
it has a delta whatever as well doesn't
it
no it doesn't it how's this
it has it i think they're for the same
reason
because there you really
just always generate and samples that's
the third usage
just the same i see i see because it's
because it's because there's no
intrinsic physical
frame rate underneath it's just values
what what you're requesting stephen to
me
seems like table of the function
start and step and then we pass that
list
as we do an image one image two model
case
to video generator and then resample
that to get the
desired frame rate yes yeah
it kind it does make sense to me okay
all right hey there's a number of
interesting comments on our live stream
here um steve
coast points out it used to be the case
in
long long ago in a version far far away
that if there was a series of graphics
in successive cells
that you could roll up those cells and
make an animation out of those cells
uh we've lost that functionality it
occurs to me
that we could perfectly well at least in
the
um uh suggestions bar
have such functionality i mean it's easy
to do you just use list animate
right or actually what is that what is
the most
the best modern way to do that animated
image
animated image as well yep that's the
more modern one
why do we have two list animate has the
play pause
all the decor decorations around the
actual content
animated image is just an animation of
the frames
so i mean the question is it does not
seem like an unreasonable thing to be
able to do
i'm not sure that in modern times it's
the most important because i mean
basically
to have generated it in modern times
you'd be dealing with essentially um
you know if i say uh do print
you know i don't know what right thing
is style
you know
oh gosh i don't even know how to do this
and i say
from letter number wow this is kind of a
messy way to do it
functional programming is much better
here um
to put it mildly but anyway i 10 or
something
okay great and now i select this range
of cells
and you know i'd like to be able to say
animate that range of cells
so in other words if i pick up if i
instead of doing do i do table here
you are saying if i say animated image
here
probably want to take the printout
yes i do
oh come on guys come on you should
imagine
them you should imagify them
what happened that's definitely oh
oh you don't want the map you just want
at
oh yeah yeah
why didn't that auto rasterize
i thought animated image uh was dealing
with any kind of expression i'll look at
it again
okay but that's working very nicely
but now the question is if you have a
range of cells
should you be able to animate them if if
nothing else for old times sake
i mean you certainly could have a right
click menu that lets you do that
maybe this is not the right group to
discuss that comments
doesn't seem it doesn't seem a modern
thing to want to do but
i i don't know i don't i cannot
immediately
let's uh scott if you can
put that in the user assistance meeting
and we'll ask the people there
okay if you don't mind going back
quickly to the video generator thing
thinking more about it i
do have a small objection um
so let's say that the function
uses the specification start and
offset that determines the frame rate
for the generation and then the frame
rate
option to sample it and plop it into a
video
as you are proposing yep um
now your function wants to take
around numbers right so you say f
duration time from zero to whatever
um with a step of one
so then you produce a function that
essentially has a domain
from between one to a hundred now
does the frame rate from the video
generator option
uh just sample this as a 100 long
100 seconds long video
no how no look
look i i'm confused here the second
argument is the duration
so the duration might be five seconds
for example
okay so we take the frame rate relative
to the duration okay fine i think i
think i
know how to do it perfect okay all right
a number of other comments that exist
here uh comment about spherical video
what do we understand about that do we
know anything about that
we'll look into all of these variations
okay
give us this release and maybe event 13
to
wrap up 2d video
comment that we should make our own
video format you know i'm i'm
i'm not encouraged by what is that what
is the variable
um vp9 i don't think it's
it doesn't sound like a good idea i mean
just
we could join this zoo
why are there so many can anybody
explain that to me
well some of them were clearly
introduced for
a better life with all of these gigantic
videos so
like uh really h.264 h265
family are shrinking the file size
dramatically and they're nice
but um i i really as well think a lot of
them are coming from devices
at some point when there were really no
single popular format
i see it's not like uh
um you know
vhs and betamax it's probably more than
that
yeah also there is not an equal share
between all of these right it's
it's not like all of these are equally
popular yeah right
okay your player if you only have
quicktime on your system
it it supports very few codecs
and the same happens to be the windows
player it's very few codecs
and a web browser too very few codecs
well isn't it nice that we can support
so many now all we need is an
in notebook fully functional in notebook
player and we'll be in great shape
but i assume that the the pop-out player
does correctly support all these codecs
right
this is your os that's but if you
right click and say minimal or basic
appearance
then we can play any of those that you
had listed under encoders
in fact under decoders okay
okay cool so that so we've successfully
got all of we've
successfully curated all those encoders
yep yeah but this is this isn't the
player steven don't get get
too excited okay all right okay fine
uh question from ethan can i stream
frames into a video
egf append frame
other outside of video generator no
you can join videos
but that's expensive if you want to do
it one at a time one frame at a time
right yeah i think you i mean you'd have
to have some other
way to view the video so it's a little
bit unclear how that works so i suppose
the idea would be if you are separately
looking at a file
and okay so this is the scenario i think
we're writing out a file with a video in
it and that file is progressively
getting longer and longer
but we have something else that's
watching that file i think that's the
scenario
i don't think we currently have a way to
do that because we have to write the
file
i mean you can't do that it's like video
that's why you end up with these weird
things that saying you have a damaged
video and so on
because the video encoding formats
aren't
just frame by frame right yes
okay comment from harry here what
happens to video
variable frame rate videos heavily used
apparently in screen capture
applications
interesting question is that very high i
didn't
get it is that no no variable frame rate
variable frame rate so i
i imagine like this screen capture for
example that's happening i don't even
know how this works
the for whatever it is the the vnc like
thing
that is you know that we're running
through zoom and through all these other
layers here that the claim would be that
that
is using some kind of variable frame
rate i don't think i've seen that
variable bit rate we have seen variable
frame rate i haven't seen
i'll look into that as well okay look it
up um
it's an interesting question whether if
i say
um what is it called uh what is it
called capture what is the screen
capture called
um image capture or
um screen karen
karen's screen image oh that's right
current screen image
what the heck is this
wow it's being out asking me to do all
kinds of stuff here
interestingly it has already returned
well it's already returned it returned
something blank
story your other some other desktop who
knows
no because all my desktops i have no
idea
um
hmm i don't know what this is doing
uh i see i have to check
a button here
will not be able to record the contents
of your screen until it is quit
wow i didn't know this required that
i wonder whether that's documented i
wonder whether that's new in some new
version of the operating system
uh scott that's another thing for you
can you make sure that gets tracked down
sure
um that's very weird
why is that looking blue
oh because it's some kind of link what
is this
okay i'm very confused by all of this
um okay
um yeah
sandra is saying mac os permissions yeah
that's right but i i'm just surprised
it's changed
um
okay um
steve is mentioning pretty sure gif uses
variable frame rate you can see how long
each frame should exist for
that may be true for a gif i mean it's a
very primitive uh
format because it's not it's not doing
any enter frame
uh compression right it's just taking
yeah so it's probably um
and and on that we can um import frame
durations for gif
and other image formats animated image
formats but
uh we have it as well for
video all the time stamps you're saying
we can get yeah we should be able to get
all the timestamps
i haven't done it but um the the one
thing we cannot do now is to display
them
at different durations um like the
animated image averages all the
durations and come up with a uniform
frame rate to display that but
yeah right so animated image probably
needs to be updated to deal with this
variable frame rate thing yep
yep um
okay let's see uh
ethan you might want to stream an image
creating a loop into a nice video
without having to export individual
frames
stream an image created in the loop
kind of what video generator is supposed
to do right you just have to reframe it
from a loop to something that gets past
that
time parameter
um okay sander is complaining about
something i i love the way that people
complain about things that i predict
they're going to complain about
the says that it doesn't know how to
extract the nth frame in a movie
in a video quantity and come of frames
yeah but that should be documented at
least both in note and examples
i understand that it's documented but
but so this is what is what is it called
video
video frame extract video extract frames
so this can if i say
uh well frame 200 i bet it's not going
to even interpret that correctly
200 frame or 200 frames is gonna be no
yeah you see that's very weird to say
200 frames yep
yep
okay that's outside let's say 20.
fine okay but so that is the 20th frame
but that is a
really you know that is a very very very
obscure way to do
that i agree roger brought it up as well
i
i
don't think we came up with any better
way uh
can we look at the syntax again yeah
sure okay
so list of frames single frame a list of
frames
i mean we could do the rather ugly thing
of putting it in another level of list
no let's let's not
well we need a way to do this because
this is goofy right now
this is really goofy
i agree typically when you say 20 frames
you think it's the first 20 frames or
something like that
i know that's what we had thought we
were going to do and you guys talked me
out of that
that's what i wanted to do i still think
that the common case is not
no the number frame because
progressively people are going to work
with longer and longer things so you're
not going to keep track of individual
integer frames but it depends what
you're doing
i mean it does i agree
but but if you've captured the video
you're not going to keep track of the
individual frames
if you generated it yeah maybe you do
actually well i could imagine as sandra
is commenting
for scientific applications i could
imagine that yes you actually do
care because you know you realize that
some event happened you detect that some
event happened at frame 2003
right and now you can look at the frames
right around there
yeah i still think we made a right
judgment call in that
the time code people usually give time
code like if you look look at a youtube
video or something like that
when what frame should you start in on
it's not going to be
you know well you know it's not the same
1259
it's you know it's time code you know
like
34 seconds or something
maybe we should have a different name
um we have some construct that
represents like an nth element rather
than
n yeah i was thinking the same something
like an
ordered quantity
it's the opposite of scaled yes
and quantity is a type of rapper but it
feels odd
by the way scaled at 0.7 would be a nice
thing to have here
okay yeah
okay but yeah that's a good idea yep
everywhere scaled could be supported
i mean maybe we should have a separate
function called video numbered frame or
something
i'm telling you people are going to want
this
just for this frame extraction fine but
then there are a lot of other functions
that take
time specification we don't want like
what all of those duplicated
like video split
there we support as well what second or
what frame to split that
yes i just think this quantity frames is
really horrible
so you've pointed out maybe we need a
symbolic wrapper for this
that's all it takes if we can if we can
if we do that then that will
fit everywhere and we probably come up
with other things too
yeah i mean we could obviously have a
wrapper like numbered frame
so that makes it very specific and not
so generic
it could be just nth element
no because that's too confusing i mean
let me think about this for a second so
the issue is
for functions that normally take a
continuous variable
see this is a weird case because there
is there's a continuous variable looking
i mean it's like data range for array
plot or something where there is
discrete data but you are mapping it
onto some continuous range
all right let's keep going with this
agenda we need to come back to this item
okay okay um
sandra is commenting that he hadn't
noticed this frames thing well and i
don't blame him because it's really
obscure
um
okay hobbyist is asking what's the point
of using all these formats because of
compression
absolutely and compression really
matters for videos
um
right okay uh
okay let's go on all right
generated asset format
is is that what we discussed we just
discussed generated asset location
last time correct
and this is a proposal to specify to be
able to specify
i1 and mp4 yeah even though in principle
it doesn't matter because you're just
going to be reading it in
here but if you need it for some
external purpose you might care about
that asset type
yep i don't disagree video
stream capture is coming
from screen video recording and video
capture
there is no video capture yet we talked
about having user interface
functions for video capture video screen
capture
those are coming in the next iteration
video record is going to be the
programmatic way that you say
i have a stream a video stream connected
to
my screen or my webcam and then you can
run video record to start recording that
into a file
so i'd like to remind you of something
which we've never built out which is
this client value concept
okay so the issue is you're going to
measure magnetic field
on your phone with the magnetometer okay
what can you measure right one thing you
could do is say
get me the instantaneous magnetic field
right when i run this function
another is put me up a user interface
which when i press the button
measures the instantaneous magnetic
field another is
make me something which will record you
know
a time series of magnetic fields from
the time i press go to the time i press
stop
right and we have a framework for
thinking about those three different
cases
that make sense
and you know we've never built that out
we started
um but it seems like you're gonna need
the exact same thing here
oh it's and uh
let's see we had i guess ricardo was the
person who we had started building that
out with
but it's the client value framework and
you should probably look at it
do i need to bring it i mean it's some
uh we really had looked at
let me just see if i can pump it up for
a second there was also the packet
capture was that following that
framework
somewhat packet capture has its own
separate issues yes it does
it does that's right it does more or
less follow that framework yes you're
absolutely right
um just see if i can pull this up
for a second
oh how depressing the stuff is all from
2015 and 2016.
ah sigh the good news is we eventually
get these things done
the bad news is sometimes takes a while
and there is also device framework
that doesn't seem too far from all of
these either
right but that has read in buffalo with
instantaneous value of a trailing time
series
record time series oh gosh yes that's
right then you have the question whether
you're recording it into a time series
whether you're recording it in um
uh just as a sequence of values yes uh i
would like to
have is it possible for me to have
access to some of these uh notebooks
sure
uh if you ask um somebody from um
project management they should be able
to give you that thanks in the client
value subdirectory
or scott could copy the whole thing yeah
thank you very much
um
oh that's right we talked about in
that's right this was the idea
so
when you have a form right you can have
something which whenever you bring up
the form it has
a magnetometer gauge
which shows you all the time it's like
like how you can see you know an audio
gauge it keeps on showing you the values
and then when you press the button
in this case it's showing you the
magnetometer values in real time on your
phone
you press the button it records the
value
see what i'm saying
no okay another case says
you have a form and one of the things it
does is
as you submit the form it captures the
magnetic field
another thing is this recorder where
you're doing essentially like a you know
a time time recording and
yeah there's a no ui case where it just
picks up the value it just does a
function call and picks up the value
yeah so with respect to video and audio
this has the additional
uh difference that the single value case
is a valid case
but it's a valid case here as well yeah
this is what i'm saying in video and
audio it isn't
it isn't video okay that would be the
image case right
yeah and in audio i mean it sort of
actually is it's the instantaneous
pressure
just not a thing one usually looks at
yeah i guess you could argue that i
could also be interpreted as their
instantaneous buffer
that's different i mean yes but we've
identified that the value
i don't see why the value isn't the
perfectly valid thing i mean it's
it is the instantaneous value of the you
know sound intensity presumably
yeah okay that's fair although there's a
question of phase
well okay but i i don't think it's
completely crazy to do that
um
let's see okay let's keep going here
nick suggests can quantities be
separated into ordinal and cardinal
units
interesting uh we don't want to seem too
trans-finite
for people who are just trying to
request the
200th frame in a video but um i agree
that ordinal quantities is an
interesting idea
which we have not really considered it's
another thing scott that's the thing
for i guess for um
oh where can we put that
maybe in an ild meeting okay
um we will bring up
nominal and ordinal scales and
visualization
next week oh
can you make sure there's somebody from
the quantity framework there then
uh yeah jose is well aware of it okay
okay fine
okay although it's probably i mean the
content of the quantity stuff is more
michael
i mean is that going to affect you know
degrees fahrenheit
versus kelvins and things or what not at
all okay
no there are things like strongly
disagree
agree neutral okay okay fine oh i see
nominal in that sense
okay a question here about gpu
acceleration
saying video frame map and so on should
have a target device option
it really depends on the encoder encoder
that you use
if your the encoder that you're that
you're using is
uh gpu accelerated then you'll get it if
no it won't
but the gpu acceleration you're talking
about carlo is
only going to eva to be available for
encoding and decoding
itself not for the processing yeah but
we don't really have
functions that uh compute arbitrary
expressions on gpus
yet right yet
um okay so it's not not a thing so far
um
i mean that's the the issue is some of
these operations that we're doing
could presumably be written for gpus and
once the compiler is up to being able
to target for gpus which probably won't
be that long
that is a realistic thing to do for some
of these functions i would think
isn't it yep i mean is our internal
representation uniform enough that we
did something like
a um i don't know some operation i don't
know blurring or something
could we do that in one way for all of
the import export formats
otherwise do we have an internal format
that is independent of the import export
formats
yeah so we're operating
you know what every function we so then
i don't understand actually
why isn't then then we are compiling all
of our operations
into things that can be done with
essentially libraries that operate with
these particular import export formats
is that right
no i think there is a misunderstanding
here most operations that we do we
import the frames
into the kernel treat them as
expressions
and then write them out yes some of
these operations where we can find
some direct translation to uh
library operation we try to do that but
we're just starting that
okay complete coverage this is kind of
true for
all outer core stuff like sometimes
there's usually a small set of
operations that can be done
close to the data source
but it's nowhere near as big as the ones
that we usually support
and yes it is conceivable though to
eventually be able to compile
an operation and pass that open that
code to the library
so that also happens close to the data
service but we're not doing that yet
okay
why are we calling this video record not
video capture
it doesn't have a user interface this is
the program
but we're going to have it oh yeah we
will you're coming it's coming
okay all right okay so it's the same
framework as this
client value thing and so on yep
um
sandra is complaining about the bad
choice of in the video extract frames
the bad choice of making the default be
seconds
[Laughter]
why i can't see his comment
where is it yeah
it's just a gamble on what will be the
most common usage i guess
right right and i understand that for
scientific uses
frames are important i kind of i i sort
of understand when you generate them
yourself where you're sort of in
very detailed control over everything
you probably think that way
more naturally
right okay ethan is commenting since
you're adding net encoders we'll have
ones with multiple ports per channel and
track
12.3 should really have some neural net
applications
of training 3d convernets on videos
what is this well this is the wrong team
to talk about that but uh
roger you're probably the crossover
person here
yeah it's it's um
those extensions are being added
basically
um i think that we're focusing on the
net encoders the coders for now
now but i think we're also pushing for
having some networks in the repository
and some
some examples definitely by the time 12
3's out that's the goal
okay that's news to me great well this
is
okay all right but you know we were also
trying to push for this
higher you know the arrays in the in the
core framework
being higher higher rank
you mean okay well that's a separate
thing
i mean is that relevant i mean i thought
we could do any rank
i don't see why it cares well i don't
know
all right let's keep going here video
time stretch
is that really okay is that something
people often want to do
i guess it is a slow motion video etc
okay then speed up yeah okay
boring parts how many have times have
you seen people
unwrapping and unpacking their nice new
toy
or assembling it speeding through the
boring parts
so how what is the mapping how do you
specify
applies time stretching to video
blah
let's see
so the easy case you just speed up or
slow down the whole video with a single
factor
but the interesting case is where you
want to speed up or slow down
just a specific time interval
well what happens if you want to
smoothly you know i don't know
that looks sensible or not but you know
you want to
gradually you know you want to have some
tanch function or something that
specifies to speed up
we're we're going to have some
transition some smooth transition
that is not customizable into all three
and then we're going to have probably
options introduced later
that would allow for custom transitions
oh what's that arbitrary function
case but then arbitrary function can
exactly as you said
specify whatever uh whatever function
whatever smooth function or non-smooth
function
okay to speed up and slow down but so so
i don't quite understand so this is
given
the function takes in the timestamp
as seconds perhaps
yes how how would you specify that you
want to give it as frame number
so sorry we we can't i think
at this point and the function has to
have some continuity properties like if
i feed in
some random cattle set or something for
how i want faster wants to go
you just can't do that because you have
to you know this is a transformation on
the interval
right so so the value of the function
though is not the
target timestamp is the ratio by which
that timestamp will be stretched or that
interval will be stretched no i
understand so it's like a metric
it's like a jacobian or something it's
it's telling you
um so in other words given an interval
right you're deforming the interval
by it's like those those um you know
weird maps where you emphasize
one you know country or what are those
called chloroplasts or something
what are those things called you know
you know what i mean where you're where
the
you're deforming the map of the earth
depending on you know which country has
the largest number of elephants or
something in it
yeah cartograms i don't think there is
there are requirements
of continuity there right says again i'm
not sure there are requirements of
continuity at least in our specific
application
you could have interval uh the first
interval with a stretch ratio of
1 and the second of 100 and wouldn't
really make any difference
no i understand but what okay what
you've got is a range in domain you've
got
the initial function right the initial
thing that's going uniformly sampling
from zero to one
and that's mapping into a thing that
samples from
i see it doesn't need to be from zero to
one so it's just taking every
element of that input
and mapping it to some element of the
output yeah exactly yeah okay so
so in other words in fact that second
case is a piecewise
specification yep it's constant
right right right right right so what
you're saying is
so the final position that you're at is
the integral
of so let's say that your mapping
function is
f of t or something then
then t maps to the integral of f of t
yeah i from correct integral of f of tau
from
tau goes up to t that's correct
okay fine
okay video insert
okay did we not have that before so
that's like putting up putting up
a header or something inserting yep you
reviewed that 12-2
it didn't make it as well as 12 as well
as video
replace okay video join now except the
list of videos a padding option what did
it do before
i mean it should presumably be like join
which is verox
i yeah which one did both accepted
initially was just better than we
decided as a convenience to also accept
the list
okay i honestly think the other way
around
and i uh wrote my note wrong
i think we only implemented a list of
videos accepted in video join
no i was it was the opposite okay okay
okay um
did we have all this before transcode
what's this
fitting what's modes for services
services is not going to make it
facebook instagram you can have
ads as well as the main content and we
would like to eventually get those as
modes of service in there so that's
metadata it's a metadata tag
uh not necessarily note that there are
specs that are provided by these
services
so facebook says i want square add
images
at that frame rate and so forth so if if
we have the most up-to-date spec
we can transcode to that spec
wait wait wait a minute this is they
insert
so you're watching a video and suddenly
an ad pops up
so that ad matches the frame rate and
things of the ambient video or that ad
is just some other
thing that's being played that was just
a a pure inserted video
that the video player is saying okay now
i'm playing this let me go to a
different thing
i think typically it's a separate thing
that pops off
i i wasn't thinking about youtube
specifically but
facebook you could have for instance you
could have main content video as well as
ad videos
and typically the aspect ratios frame
rate and so forth for those ads
could be different from the main content
this is like themes stephen this is my
name
what you misspelled pinterest here yes
but that's futurist i am still still
wrong
but but it's like themes i mean in most
many
other editing software if you're gonna
sort of upload
you know to say facebook or something
they suggest
they have sort of that they have a
ready-made thing so you don't have to
think about you don't have to go and
read specs
i i understand and it's the thing you
have to
upload if you don't want your video
cropped in weird ways and so on
yeah okay well so you're saying we have
that already or
video transcode we have the services
that you see we have
as of 12 2 but the modes we don't have
and we're not going to get them in 12
3 there okay what what is being updated
is the bitrate option there as well as
that frame fitting
so in case your video has a 16 to 9
aspect ratio and then you would like to
you request
a square aspect ratio what happens
do we crop do we stretch all of those
fitting
modes could be specified under the new
frame fitting
again name is on the table for debate
i'm gonna have to run i have a
connection so i also need to run
um i think we're gonna need to do a part
two of this yes i expected as much
oh boy okay yes
um all right well roger you may have to
disappear here i think
let me just respond to a couple other
things on our live stream
um
um let's see
huh notebook screen recording should
have an option for highlighting mouse
clicks
they are boy yes i don't know what we're
doing with that i mean
clearly screen recording just got more
complicated because of new os
requirements it's a question from rbs
will you support
3dfx glide i don't know what that is
i'm looking it up now
um okay well there'll be more advanced
feature tracking for objects and videos
yes not in not immediately in 12
3 unless there is well currently as well
we could we could do something like
video map
time series or video map list that takes
consecutive frames
but if you want to do bigger smoothing
over
multiple spans i guess
that's going to be coming fair enough
okay rbs come one do crossfades between
videos
um what kind of thing can one do for the
transitions
so you could handcraft yours using
a video frame map with two
inputs as a video but we don't have any
built-in functionality to do that which
we should have
i i agree i i think post 123
one big project for video is to have
custom functions
like potentially video assemble video
crossfade and things like that
implemented based on and using our video
map
function family yeah
i'll be asked to support super eight
millimeter
frame rates fps what
surely yes i mean isn't that just a slow
frame rate i don't know what super 8
frame rate was but it's something 16
frames per second or something
i think yes i also remember something
slow but i don't remember the
exact number 24.
yeah i don't i don't think there's a
problem with that i said i tested up to
like one frame per second everything
seems to work
and it really depends mostly on the
player that you'll use then to open the
file
yeah i know i know that's why i'm saying
i don't really believe in these things
but i mean
i've i say this not completely
inadvisedly because i know for things
like
image display you say oh you can use any
size of pixel in postscript for example
in the postscript image operator well
except that there are
there used to be bugs in it right
because nobody
who ever wants a single pixel unless
you're doing cellular automaton images
whoever wants a single pixel in an image
that is
you know a millimeter across for example
right and so it's just not something
well supported and so people just have
you know
lots of bugs with that um okay this
3d fx guide is apparently an old style
shader architecture
so don't know um all right let's just
scan ahead just to get a sense of what
we're
going to see next time audio
image okay
boy lots of cool stuff okay
good all right well
the question here just came in from rfir
and iir
implemented for audio processing
everything should be there yeah yep what
is the name of the function that does
like final impulse response
how do you do that oh wow um
i mean you can make
it's a while
but you make the filter and then you um
uh you do have list convol we do have
recurrence filter
so again
recurrence filter should be the iar
filter okay
god this this stupid thing with this
thing
okay and and you can use that in a video
you know
in audio yep that's the last use case
it says sound but the audio is supported
there too
that's cool sandra is commenting on
needing wanting to see speed ups and
rasterize
calming how
this was really old code we were
uncompressed
compressing then uncompressing data
between front
rasterize is done by the front end the
kernel
front end connection is being sped up
then there were more inefficiencies that
we got rid of
okay so that's in 12.3 yes cool
what's the factor of by how much is it
faster
really depends on the size of the image
and how much
it was compressible we're not
compressing anything anymore
before if it was um
really not compressible like a random
image
we were spending a lot of time
compressing it but the size wasn't going
down so still sending a lot of data over
the link
and then uncompressing it again
factors we're looking at mostly between
you know
four or five times faster is what we're
seeing in a
thousand by thousand two thousand by two
thousand images
so if i do this like
oh that image is probably really larger
right because that style
right although the timing didn't
increase much i mean let me do 500
not enough memory able to rasterize that
well that's a different problem
okay 0.05 and if i now say that
in the current version
that not enough memory thing is that a
front end problem or what
um i'll have the plane buffer not large
enough
i i think so
unless it's really producing a huge
image that
now i done
oh wow yep that's about what we're
seeing across board but again it really
varies
how compressible it was okay
sanders should be happy i'm happy too
i've needed this a bunch of times
wow that's really good should have done
that a long time ago
okay and by the way why did the
rendering um
um why did this rendering look different
here
because you have i think rasterize is
using the
window formatting with or some such
argument image formatting with your
notebook with that magnification
if you evaluate that style yeah
and evaluate it again it's gonna wow
okay uh
ethan is commenting we should rasterize
in tiles to avoid these frame buffer
memory problems
yeah well let's find out what that
actually is because it might be
something more bizarre than that it
might be to do with font rendering
because what i was asking for
was an absolutely humongous font and
that may be something deep in the
operating system
um okay good stuff
thanks all very much look forward to the
next time and thanks to folks on the
live stream
and